[Applause]
thank you
that's Gabriel wrench who was arrested
for a prayer protest during the pandemic
he and two other Christians recently
settled for three hundred thousand
dollars after they sued the city of
Moscow Idaho for violating their first
and Fourth Amendment rights French's
response he feels bad for taxpayers he
says the settlement comes at a high cost
to city taxpayers and estimates the city
spent about five hundred thousand
dollars of City resources on this fight
when police violated wrench's
constitutional rights they didn't have
to pay taxpayers did and this keeps
happening like when cops body slam
people shoot a fenced dog Capital Marine
veteran for filming a cop from his porch
or they jail you for free speech if
taxpayers take the hit every time
something like this happens police have
no incentive to change or to stop hiring
bad apples and even worse we won't see
incidents of police abuse decline